Okay, let's start. Welcome to the DDPS
seminar, everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speakers, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions.
If you have questions, you are welcome
to unmute and ask. Otherwise, please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in Q&A session at
the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed.
So, please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now, let me introduce
our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Ricardo Vinuessa,
who is an associate professor at the
Department of Engineering Mechanics at
KTH, the Royal Institute of Technology
in Stockholm.
He is also a researcher at the KTH
Climate Action Centre and vice director
of the KTH
KTH
Digitalization Platform. He studied
Mechanical Engineering at the
Polytechnic University of Valencia in
Spain, and he received his PhD in
Mechanical and Aerospace Engineering
from the Illinois Institute of
Technology in Chicago.
His research combines numerical
simulations and data-driven methods to
understand and model complex
wall-bounded turbulent flows, such as
the boundary layers
um and developing around wings and urban
environments.
Dr. Vinuessa has received, among others,
an ERC Consolidator Grant and the Göran
Gustafsson Award for young researchers.
Today, Ricardo will talk about modeling
and controlling turbulent flows
through deep learning, which will be
very interesting. So, please enjoy a
wonderful talk. Now, without further
ado, let me pass the button to Ricardo
by asking one random questions as usual.
Today's random question is, what is your
favorite things to do other than
research?
Traveling.
Traveling, yeah. How many kids do you
have?
Uh sorry, I meant traveling, but family
is
said Oh, you said traveling.
But family is a good answer, too.
Okay.
Sorry to misunderstand you.
No, no problem. No problem.
Yeah, you are doing the traveling right
now, actually.
Yeah, exactly. I'm spending uh some days
some weeks now in the in the US,
actually. So, it's very very nice.
Okay. Okay, the stage is yours.
Yeah, thank you very much for the kind
invitation. It's also an honor for me to
to be presenting in this prestigious
seminar series.
And as mentioned in the introduction,
I'm going to be talking about turbulence
and deep learning. My research is funded
mainly by the ERC consolidator grant,
the European Research Council, but there
are other sources like the like CIRC,
which is the Swedish e-Science Research
Council,
uh for
for e-Science technologies. So, I'm
going to start by uh talking a little
bit about success stories of machine
learning.
This technology is showing a lot of
potential in a wide range of areas,
including predicting text, economics, or
image classification, as we can see in
this slide.
One of the first examples of data-driven
methods being able to tackle complex
tasks was when in 1997 the IBM Deep Blue
machine defeated Garry Kasparov, who was
the world champion of chess at the time.
He didn't take the defeat so well,
actually. Uh and it turns out that
playing chess is actually quite easy for
a machine.
Because essentially through brute force
computing, one can get quite quite good
performance.
And one can define the complexity of
a game. And games are very widely used
in machine learning because they define
narrow but challenging tasks.
One can define it by taking the number
of moves that you can do in a typical
turn
and raise it to the power of the number
of turns that a typical game has. So, as
we can see here,
the numbers of chess are much lower than
those of the game of Go, you know, which
has become now very popular
thanks to Google and DeepMind. So, this
metric of M to the power of T
is many, many orders of magnitude
larger, you know, in the case of Go. And
this this game Go
actually requires some sort of
intuition, some sort of strategic
thinking to be able to be to be played,
you know. I mean, it's not enough
with just a brute force computing and
analyzing all the possibilities. One
needs to be able to really try to
predict and
foresee in the future what the
developments are going to be.
And the
trying to leverage the potential of
machine learning
the team of
DeepMind, Silver and others in 2016,
they published in Nature their work
developing the AlphaGo algorithm, you
know. So, in this algorithm, they showed
the games of the best human players of
Go.
And they could actually defeat the world
champion Lee Sedol, as you can see here,
by four against one using this
algorithm. That was a very
well, very astounding accomplishment
because it was expected that the machine
learning would be able to play Go in
quite some decades ahead, but actually
was achieved now six years ago. So, that
was quite some some remarkable resource
there. And maybe even more interesting
is the next evolution of this algorithm,
which was the AlphaGo Zero. And in
AlphaGo Zero,
the algorithm is not given any
knowledge, any human knowledge. It's
just given the rules of the game.
And then the algorithm by playing
against itself using reinforcement
learning
is able to, as you can see here, this is
the performance as a function of the
training time. In less than two days of
training, it was able to reach a
superhuman performance. So, actually,
there was quite some interesting
potential
of this technology for this narrow task
without using any human input, no? Just
using the strategies that was that were
developed through self-learning in this
playing against itself in this
reinforcement learning context. So,
there is quite some interesting
areas, no? Where machine learning can
actually be applied. We have a recent
article in Nature Communications where
we looked at how AI, more generally AI,
can affect the Sustainable Development
Goals of the United Nations. It turns
out that 79% of these goals can be
positively affected by AI, whereas 35%
can be negatively affected by AI.
One should be aware of the fact that
even if the result is mostly positive,
there are many negative areas that one
should be aware of when deploying these
technologies. And the environment and
society appear to have the largest
positive potential of this technology.
Now,
we were talking about interpretability
before. Of course, many of these
models, of these deep learning models,
are actually well, acting as black
boxes, right? So, it's really not
possible to establish a clear connection
between the inputs and the predictions
that are being obtained from those
inputs. And we argue in Nature Machine
Intelligence that for any applications
with
well, with some real impact on society,
on sustainability, on engineering
applications, one needs to develop
interpretable methods, no? And there is
some interesting work from Krammer and
others from Princeton where they added
layers of interpretability on the
already trained deep learning methods.
And we argue in our paper that that can
also be achieved as well,
basically by symbolic regression so that
one can actually make predictions that
can in fact generalize sometimes even
more than the original deep learning
model. This is a quite um
quite up-and-coming area of research.
And of course, this is very very
relevant for a very wide range of
applications.
Um
my main topic today is going to be fluid
mechanics.
And machine learning has helped fluid
mechanics in a wide range of areas.
Perhaps
a very seminal work 20 years ago by
Milano and Koumoutsakos, where they
could use neural networks to predict the
near wall region of a channel. That was
a quite interesting
seminal approach not to this data-driven
methods. More recently, there have been
studies looking at subgrid modeling for
large eddy simulations,
RANS modeling as well.
There has been quite some potential to
generate synthetic inflow and boundary
conditions that can help to produce more
efficient
CFDs. CFD
which stands for computational fluid
dynamics. So, CFD simulations. And also,
there is quite some interesting
applications to flow control to be able
to reduce the drag or enhance the
mixing. And to use PINNs,
physics-informed neural networks, in the
context of sensing as well. So, there
are some interesting directions and some
interesting areas where machine learning
is already helping and can help even
more for fluid mechanics.
In fact, we have just published in
Nature Computational Science
a review article today with Steve
Brunton,
where we highlight potential of machine
learning for CFD, you know, for
computational fluid mechanics. And what
we find is that there is quite some
potential to accelerate direct numerical
simulations, to improve the modeling
both in the context of LES and RANS, and
to improve the
robustness and generality of
reduced-order models. And I'll be
talking about that also later in this
presentation. So, both in terms of
modeling and acceleration of the
simulations, there is quite some
potential also for machine learning and
you can also read more about our
perspectives on this on this review
article that you can you can find here
in this reference. Okay?
So, today
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to focus on several examples where we
have used machine learning to either
help the modeling of turbulent flows or
enhance possibilities for controlling
those turbulent flows. And the first
example is what we call non-intrusive
So, non-intrusive sensing, what we do is
that we want to measure at the wall
so that we can predict what happens
above the wall in the flow without
having to stick sensors in the flow
itself. Because of course when we start
to put the probes, we're disrupting the
flow, we're creating other effects and
it's quite efficient to actually measure
just at the wall and perform that
prediction
dynamically at each time step. So, what
we use
is three quantities that we measure at
the wall,
the wall pressure and the two wall shear
stress components and we use computer
vision techniques, CNNs but also other
tools to predict what happens to the
three velocity fluctuations at different
wall normal locations above the wall.
So, above the wall we can actually
predict. Our one motivation for this
non-intrusive sensing approach is
flow control because if we know what is
happening on the flow at each instant,
we can design better controllers to be
able to reduce drag or do any other
application that we may want to do with
the flow.
By the way, these results are
presented in the Journal of Fluid
Mechanics so you can see the reference
here by Guastoni and others
published last year in 2021.
Okay?
So,
the first thing that we do is that we
create a database of direct numerical
simulations
DNS data using a Fourier
code.
And we consider a turbulent open
channel. So, we have one wall and a
symmetric condition at the top. That's
just to simplify slightly the dynamics
of the large scales. We consider two
Reynolds numbers, friction Reynolds
numbers of 180 and 550. These are the
domain sizes, which are large enough.
And we use this DNS data, this highly
resolved numerical data of the flow to
be able to
train the planning models to make the
predictions that I was mentioning, no?
So, from the wall to above the wall at
different locations.
And what happens is that turbulence
exhibits coherent structures, right? So,
turbulence has
certain patterns. And if we look at the
wall, those are going to be 2D images.
So, of course, using fully connected
networks are not going to be they're not
going to be very efficient in this sort
of prediction. And we go to computer
vision. So, we start with CNNs,
convolutional neural networks, to be
able to exploit the spatial correlations
of the data,
which correspond to the coherent
structures present in the flow, to be
able to leverage those and improve our
predictions, no? So, in CNNs, and I
guess most of the audience here is very
familiar with them, we essentially have
a kernel, a 2D kernel, which can have a
certain depth as well.
Which is sweeping through the input
image. And then we obtain a feature map
based on these convolution operations
that are being applied. And in this
case, since the kernel has size 3 * 3,
it's
its value of the output, which is a
feature map, each of these grid points
receives information from nine grid
points of the input. And depends that
depends on the kernel size and how we
are designing the convolutions.
So, essentially,
one of the architectures that we
consider is this one, where we have this
is a CNN, a convolutional neural
network. We have three inputs here.
Which correspond to the two wall shear
stress components and the wall pressure.
We have three outputs here. Those are
the three velocity um fluctuations at a
certain wall normal location. And we
have a total of six hidden layers uh
with a number of filters that you can
see uh on each of the layers. So, of
course um each of those filters um
is associated with a a feature map that
is identifying one or more features of
the input, uh.
And uh we can actually see that uh of
course we have a reduced number of
parameters in the first layers, no,
because of the convolutional uh aspect
of this of this architecture.
And the idea is the following. Because
we have extractors in turbulence.
And we want to be able to exploit those
spatial correlations to make
predictions.
In the first layers, we're going to
identify very abstract and simple
features on the input data. So, those
could be edges, lines, circles, things
that are quite simple. And of course,
because of the concatenated application
of convolutions, when we get closer to
the output, we will build progressively
more complex
structures, no. We'll build more
elements that are more realistic um
and and more aligned with what you have
in a turbulent flow. And that's very
interesting, right? Because what happens
is that uh through this concatenated
application of convolutions, we can uh
hierarchically build more and more
complicated features, which correspond
to the turbulent structures. And
turbulence works like that. Turbulence
is also very hierarchical. You have a
smaller scales that interact and one can
actually create produce turbulent
kinetic energy and create larger scales
in a quite hierarchical manner. So, the
way that these structures are being
produced is very nicely aligned with the
way in which CNNs learn. So, that
there's a quite nice fit there to
predict turbulent structures. One
additional note is that uh we have now
uh been working on even deeper networks.
So, if you maintain the number of
parameters constant, which means that we
reduce the number of filters per layer
but increase the number of layers, you
can actually get even better
predictions. Now, and that goes in the
direction of this concatenated
application of
convolutions that help us to really
really build very good and realistic
coherent structures. Okay?
So, this is how the CNN looks like. And
again, this is the reference in JFM. So,
these are the three wall quantities that
we're using as input, and these are the
three velocity fluctuations that we're
trying to predict. Okay?
Everything that I've shown you so far
is what we call the FCN method, the
fully convolutional network,
which relies on taking information at
the wall, which if you look at the wall
is just going to be a 2D plane, and
predicting directly the information
above the wall, which is going to be
another 2D plane.
But something that one can do instead is
rather than predicting directly the full
plane, is to do POD, proper orthogonal
decomposition or principal component
analysis, depending on what you which is
your community.
So, one can do POD on these subdomains.
Therefore, what we do is that we
separate the spatial temporal problem
into a spatial modes and temporal
coefficients, and then we only need to
predict the temporal coefficients of
those modes, right? So, this is in
principle an alternative approach that
can help us in certain cases, and this
is documented in these two references.
And this will be denoted as the FCN-POD
method. So, we will have FCN and the
FCN-POD.
So, I'm going to show you predictions at
Re tau 550. This is a Well, the higher
Reynolds number that we considered. And
these are instantaneous velocity fields
of the streamwise velocity fluctuations.
Okay?
The
first column is Y plus 15, which means
that
this is the region of the near wall
peak. And the second column is Y + 100,
which is already in the outer region.
Um the reference is the third row.
That's the one labeled as DNS. So, we
want to target these two flow fields
that you see here.
Uh the first row is based on the
extended POD. So, the extended POD is
a a method that is formally equivalent
to linear stochastic estimation. So,
essentially it's a linear prediction
between the input and the output. And
what we can see in this
in this in this comparison is that the
linear method is able to predict some
things.
Um but the problem is that
the the streaks are significantly
attenuated. And many of the non-linear
interactions due to modulation are not
very well reproduced by this method. No?
So, in a way the linear prediction
framework will capture the superposition
mechanisms of the large scales, but not
really so much the modulation, which is
a non-linear phenomenon.
If we go to the non-linear methods,
which are the CNN-based approaches, what
we see
by comparing the second and the fourth
row is that the FCN approach
basically nails the flow of Y + 15. We
can get excellent predictions of the
streaks of the near wall peak and the
near wall fluctuations. We get excellent
results there.
Of course, as we move farther away from
the wall, the the signals are less
correlated. So, it's more difficult to
get good predictions. But at Y + 100,
the FCN-POD gets better results.
And of course, there is a certain
filtering effect. We don't have a
perfect prediction of the flow at Y +
100. But the FCN-POD can identify where
the streaks are, their sizes, and their
locations. More interestingly,
we can argue because the FCN-POD works
better than the FCN that close to the
wall, you should use the FCN to predict
directly the full signal. Far away from
the wall, it's better to do POD first
and then only predict the temporal
dynamics of those spatial modes because
you can you can basically encapsulate
the information more efficiently in few
POD modes when you have these very large
scales
for which we only need to predict
basically the temporal the temporal
dynamics.
Okay?
So, this is about the instantaneous
predictions, but we can also look at the
statistical
features of the flow.
So, what we show here are the streamwise
wall normal and spanwise velocity
fluctuations.
The black line are the DNS results and
the horizontal axis is the wall normal
location in inner units.
The
The triangle is the FCN prediction. The
blue dots are the FCN POD and the square
is the extended POD, which is the linear
method.
So, what we can see by comparing with
the reference is that, of course, all
the predictions get worse as Y+
increases. That's expected. The near
wall peak is very well predicted with
FCN. So, we get less than 1% error of
the near wall peak,
which is quite remarkable.
Um and the other interesting thing is
that the at Y+ 100, the blue dot is
above the triangle. So, that's where the
FCN POD takes over and becomes a bit
better than the FCN. And in all of these
cases, the linear method is worse than
the CNN-based methods, no? I mean, as
expected as well because we can only
reproduce the linear scale interaction
mechanisms of turbulence, but not the
nonlinear ones, which are quite well
captured through the
CNN approaches. Okay? By the way, the
error that we make at Y+ 100 with the
SCN POD is 26%, which is acceptable if
you want to do flow control because then
you can actually see at least where the
large scales are.
Okay?
So,
something that we also did was transfer
learning.
So, in transfer learning, as many of you
know,
we basically try to reuse what we learn
in one task for another one that is not
too different, but not too similar
either. Uh in this case, what we are
doing at R over 180 is to take a network
trained for predictions at Y plus 15, so
close to the wall, and try to see if the
predictions at Y plus 50, which is a bit
farther away from the wall, can be
benefiting from transfer learning.
Uh to do that,
what we do is that we freeze the three
first layers.
So, as I mentioned before, these ones
are going to be identifying smaller
things and more abstract
features, and we can expect that at the
two locations the small scales are going
to be similar, and it's going to be the
larger scales that are going to be a bit
more different.
That's why we will retrain the
information of the layers closer to the
output, okay? And then you can see all
these results in the Journal of Physics
Conference Series, also by Wu and
Astonia and others.
What we do is that through transfer
learning, we can get the same uh level
of accuracy as with the original
network, but reducing the amount of
training time by a factor of more than
four. So, we can actually
train these networks for turbulence
predictions in a more efficient way.
We also did this in the context of um
Reynolds number effects.
So, we took the network that we used to
make predictions at R over 180, and the
training at R over 550
was initialized from the weights of 180,
right? So, we transferred the weights,
and instead of having random
initialization, we just started with uh
with the weights of 180. What we can see
is that we can reduce the amount of
training data again by a factor of four.
So, we can actually obtain the same
level of accuracy, but reducing much
more the amount of data,
which in this case
the simulation at 550 is
much, much more expensive than the one
at 180. So, if one can do most of the
training with a very cheap simulation
that basically you can run in your
laptop, and then the requirements for
high performance computing are
significantly reduced, then we are doing
something quite effective, no, for our
training of our deep learning models.
Now, what happens
if instead of having the full signal at
the wall, so if you take the wall
information and you look at it,
instead of having the DNS level of
resolution, you only have few sparse
measurements there, right? Which is what
would happen in a wind tunnel
experiment, in a real world realization
of this. Well, what we did was to employ
a generative adversarial network, GANs,
which again many of the people in this
audience are familiar with. This is a
schematic representation of the GANs, in
which we have two parts. We have the
generator and the discriminator.
So, the generator, what it's doing is
it's producing high resolution images
based on low resolution images that need
to
basically follow the statistical
distributions of the reference data set.
And the discriminator needs to
differentiate which of the high
resolution images were from the original
data set, and which ones were produced
by the generator, right? And because
these two networks, or these two parts
of the network, have antagonistic tasks,
they can be trained together using game
theory.
And essentially we can get a generator
that is very, very good at producing
realistic images. And that's what we
leverage here
in this architecture, which has two
steps. In the first step, we go from the
low resolution image
data at the wall to high resolution data
at the wall. And in the second step, we
use that high resolution data to produce
the predictions of the flow above the
wall, right? So, we go from coarse data
to fine data, and then to prediction.
Uh all these results are presented in
Physics of Fluids, so you can see this
article from last year. This is the
instantaneous streamwise wall shear
stress component. Uh this is the DNS, so
this is the reference. And at the top, I
am uh downsampling by a factor of 4, 8,
and 16 squared. So, you can see that the
16 squared case, this one is actually
quite coarse. Uh and this is similar to
what you could get in an experiment,
just a few measurements
uh at the wall, right?
And what you see on the second row are
the predictions.
And we can actually get
quite uh good predictions, even on the I
mean, for the low downsampling, we get
very good predictions. For the high
downsampling, even if there is an
attenuation of the streaks, we can
actually see that the streaks are in the
right location, they have the right
size, and the right spacing in the
spanwise direction. So, we can actually
use this for flow control quite
effectively, because we are getting some
insight into the characteristics of
these streaks.
And if we do now the predictions above
the wall,
what we get here in the first row is the
DNS, right? Um the first column is Y
plus 15, then 30, 50, and 100. So, we're
going progressively farther away from
the wall. And then the next rows uh are
the different downsampling levels, you
know, 4, 8, and 16. So, obviously, the
easiest prediction is this one, right?
Because this is very close to the input,
and there is a low downsampling. And you
can see that the prediction is is
excellent, it's really, really good. The
hardest prediction is this one, because
we are very far away, and we have quite
a lot of downsampling.
Even in this case, what we can see is
that uh the streaks are very well
located. So, even if I want to target
large-scale control, we can actually get
very effective uh
control approaches uh to be able to
target these structures. So, even for an
experimental realization of this flow
control or this non-intrusive sensing
plus flow control strategy, we can
actually get
very, very good results that can help us
in the context of the closed-loop
control.
Okay?
So, everything that I discussed so far
was based on predictions from the wall
to above the wall and
for non-intrusive sensing, but one can
think of the opposite problem. What
happens if I want to use information
from far away from the wall to predict
the flow closer to the wall. And this is
an important problem when one is
thinking about off-wall boundary
conditions where one wants to replace
the whole near-wall region by a boundary
condition where you can develop good
wall models
and we try to use this BRCNNs, right?
This This work you can find it in
archive and this was presented at ETMM
last year, so you can find the the
archive
preprint in there.
And essentially what we see,
we try to reproduce some of the work
that was done by Mittal and Jimenez.
So, what they did is that they took the
overlap region of a channel and
basically re-scaled the input and set it
at the
at their location close to the wall to
develop a wall model. We tried to do
something like that using CNNs and we
consider the case at R tau 550.
Uh
we are having in the three columns the
U, V, and W fluctuations. The input is
at Y plus 100, so these are the three
input quantities. Uh the output, so the
prediction which is closer to the wall
at Y plus 50 is the second row, so we're
trying to predict these quantities over
here.
And the predictions are the third row
that you can see here.
So, we can actually see that visually
the instantaneous flow is in quite good
agreement and we can reproduce if we
compare the second and the third rows,
we can reproduce most of the features of
the original data quite well.
Uh but this prediction is inherently
more complex than the previous one for
two reasons. When you're using the outer
flow to predict the flow closer to the
wall, you miss the effect of the small
scales that is imprinted at the wall.
So, that's already missing when you're
trying to make those predictions.
And second, when we are trying to uh use
a CNN to you predict from the large
scales as input, the receptive field is
going to be a small part of those large
scales uh which also complicates
extracting the relevant information from
those scales uh to make my predictions.
Um if we look at the results,
here we have the power spectral density.
This is the two-dimensional spectrum in
the streamwise and spanwise direction at
Y plus 50.
The shaded contours are the reference
and the orange lines are the prediction.
We can see that clearly we're missing
some of the small scales
uh which is not surprising. This is what
we can expect from the lack of a small
scale information at the input and some
of the energy is a bit displaced, no?
But overall, the spectra looks physical,
I mean there's a bit of a discrepancy
but still
uh it's not it's not that bad.
And we have around 20% error in the
predictions, no? Which uh
for flow control it would be good. For
imposing it as a wall model it's a bit
high, so one should also uh well, try to
explore other alternatives. But in
principle, we could solve the problem of
the missing scales with a GANs-based
approach, probably. And we can also uh
work with uh pooling, max pooling for
example, to be able to solve the problem
of the receptive field and the large
scales.
So, there are some possible strategies
that one could uh try to benefit from in
the context of these predictions.
Another problem that I'm going to
mention briefly,
and if you're interested in it, we can
also discuss it more later. It's the use
of physics informed networks, PINs,
for RANS simulations. And RANS
simulations are um
the simulations based on Reynolds
averaging, where we are actually um
trying to uh to model the the
contribution of the Reynolds stresses to
the mean flow. This work has been
published recently in Physics of Fluids,
so you can see the reference here.
And what we see
is that with PINs, we can take the 2D
RANS equations for incompressible flow,
and use the PINs framework to solve
these equations without any model for
the Reynolds stresses. So, the Reynolds
stresses are variables that are being
solved
as part of the as part of the um
algorithm that we're trying. Okay?
And let's keep in mind that PINs
uh
PINs uh is basically trying to minimize
the residual of the RANS equations, so
it's
trying to solve the uh
the governing equations in a similar way
to what you would do with a spectral
element method or a finite difference
method. Uh the only advantage of PINs is
that you can get away with coarser
resolutions, because with automatic
differentiation, you need to really
resolve the gradients so much. You still
need to resolve some things, some
propagate information to the boundaries,
but you don't need to resolve the
gradients so much. And certain niche
applications, like in RANS for example,
one can actually get uh at a similar
computational cost than that of the
industrial RANS simulations, um
basically, uh we can get a performance
that is much better than um
that of typical RANS models, basically.
So, this is a periodic hill. This is a
typical example of flow with separation.
There's a
quite big challenge, no, for um
for uh models. And we're comparing with
DNS, and we can see that we get a very
good representation of the separation
bubble, the reattachment, and the
streamlines. So, we get uh around two or
three percent error in the mean, a bit
higher error in the Reynolds stresses,
but you can actually see that we get a
very good representations of the DNS
data in this flow configuration. Okay?
So, PINNs can actually help us, um,
and of course, uh, there is some
limitations as well, but in certain
niche applications, we can actually get
interesting results from PINNs. Okay?
Now, another example that I like quite a
bit is that of, uh, using, um,
reduced order models, uh,
and and utilizing the advantages of
autoencoders to build non-linear reduced
order models, in turbulent flows. So, we
can actually, uh, try to obtain
non-linear reduced order models,
uh, by re- reconstructing the nice
properties of POD, which are the
optimality and the orthogonality of
these, uh, representations. Okay? And,
uh, through the orthogonality, we're
going to try to have, uh, interpretable
non-linear modes. Uh, this work was
published also this year in Expert
Systems with Applications, so this is
the reference. Uh, and I'm going to be
describing in a little bit, first of
all, the data set.
So, there has been some work of, uh,
autoencoders on 2D cylinders, but this
is one of the first applications to a
turbulent flow, a complex turbulent
flow.
This is a well-resolved large eddy
simulation, very detailed flow, uh, in a
simplified urban environment, so the
flow between two buildings. You can see
the level of detail that we can, uh,
obtain, and you can see Lapita and, uh,
and others for more details. And we have
a total of 1,200 instantaneous flow
visualization, uh, flow realizations,
uh, to be able to train our reduced
order models.
So, we consider different
autoencoder-based architectures, and the
first one is the classical CNN
autoencoder. As mentioned before,
turbulence has, uh, a certain spatial,
uh, information and spatial correlations
that can be exploited through CNNs.
That's why we employ the CNN
autoencoder.
As many of you know, an autoencoder is a
deep learning architecture in which
you're trying to reproduce the original
data, reconstruct original data, but
you're applying progressively dimension
reductions until you find a very compact
representation of the original data in
the latent space, right? Which is the
bottom neck of the autoencoder.
So, this is the CNN-based autoencoder,
quite a standard.
The second one is the hierarchical
autoencoder.
And this one is a aimed at obtaining the
optimality property of POD. We want to
obtain modes that are ranked based on
their contribution to the
reconstruction. And the this was
proposed by Fukami and others.
What the way that this works is that you
have first um
an autoencoder configuration where the
latent space has size one and that
allows us to obtain the first latent
variable, the first latent vector.
Fixing that
latent vector, we have another
autoencoder of size two where we want to
train uh and obtain a new latent
variable R2, which is able to
reconstruct original signal by fixing
R1. And we can do that recursively. In
the third autoencoder, we fix modes one
and two and we want to fix the third one
by fixing the dimension of the latent
space to three so that we can obtain a
sequence of modes that have
progressively less and less contribution
towards the reconstruction. Okay?
None of the autoencoder configurations
that I mentioned so far gives you
orthogonal modes. And that's a desirable
property if you are building a
reduced-order model because you want the
modes to be able to be interpretable.
Okay?
To be able to embed the orthogonality,
we consider beta variation autoencoders,
which are ways in which we we can
introduce a stochasticity in our model.
So, we consider that P of X is the
distribution of the original data.
P of R is the distribution of the data
in the latent space, okay? And the goal
of the beta VAE is to maximize this
quantity, uh uh
where P theta of X is the marginal
likelihood. So, it's basically an
approximation of the original data given
the parameters theta of the network.
So, in the variational auto encoders
framework uh this quantity over here
that which basically wants to give me
the marginal likelihood of the original
data given that the that we have the
latent
latent space variables, this is what we
call the decoder because it will
obtain or it will recover the original
data. And this is of course a generative
model. So, we're sampling from the
latent space distribution to obtain the
generative model of the original data.
And com- conversely, this distribution
over here of R, which is the latent
variables given the original variables,
this is an encoder, right? Which would
be the recognition model that takes us
from the original space into the latent
space. And the decoder will take us from
the latent space to the original
through the reconstruction that we want
to have. Okay?
So, this would be the setup for a beta
variational auto encoder.
The interesting thing
and the way in which we can introduce
stochasticity is that in the encoder, we
assume a Gaussian distribution like this
one.
Okay? And we can sample from this
marginal likelihood, from this
distribution
through an auxiliary normal distribution
of noise. So, we have the latent
variables are given here. Mu is the
mean, sigma the standard deviation, and
this noise follows a normal
distribution. So, the loss of the beta
VAE
is given by this quantity over here.
Where we are introducing a penalization
factor beta, that's where the name comes
from, which promotes two different
things. First of all, we want to promote
a learning statistical independent
latent variables, right? Which basically
minimize the distance between PR and the
product of its marginals. And on the
second and on the second side, we want
to minimize the size of the latent
space, so we can learn a parsimonious
and disentangle
representation of the data in the latent
space. That's what the beta VAE is
doing.
Uh and of course, this is a
hyperparameter. I'll tell you more about
its effect.
This is how the how the model looks
like. So, the decoder is the generative
model where I can recover the original
data by sampling from the latent space,
and the encoder is the one where I am
obtaining the variables in the latent
space.
Okay?
Um so, these are some results. Um this
is the a reference instantaneous field
that you can see here. This is the flow
between the two obstacles.
If I take five POD modes, I only
reconstruct 72% of the energy.
Whereas with the autoencoder approaches,
I am always around 90% of energy. In
fact, the beta VAE is
87% of the energy with orthogonal modes,
and I will show you more about the
orthogonality. Here you can appreciate
the level of detail that we can obtain
with the reconstruction, which
basically tells me
that with this autoencoder-based
model reduction, I can obtain very
compact reduced-order models. With five
POD autoencoder modes, I can reconstruct
a significant fraction of the energy.
Whereas for POD, I would require
hundreds of modes,
which in principle tells me a little bit
of the potential
of these
autoencoders for turbulent flow
simulations and turbulent flow modeling.
This is the determinant of the
correlation matrix among the five first
modes. As you can see, of course, the
POD has 100% orthogonality. The beta
variational autoencoder has more than
99% orthogonality, which means that a
certain physical phenomenon will be
mapped to a particular mode and not a
number of modes. And the orthogonality
of the other two autoencoder approaches
is actually quite low, right? So,
in principle, if we want to promote
interpretable modes, the beta
variational autoencoder approach is
actually quite convenient.
There is an interesting effect of the
beta parameter.
So, of course, here I'm plotting the
parameter beta, and I'm representing you
the orthogonality, which increases with
the parameter beta. And the percentage
of reconstruction reconstructed energy
will decrease with beta, obviously,
right? Also,
the number of nonzero variables um
is decreased when I am increasing the
parameter beta. So, of course, the
penalization, if I have a higher
penalization, I will have a more
parsimonious model, I will have fewer
variables in the latent space, and I
will also
have more orthogonal variables, but I
will have a worse reconstruction, right?
Through the penalization that I'm
introducing. So, you can see how the
latent variables
are actually changing
when I'm reducing the value of beta. I
have a total of 10 nonzero variables
with the smallest value of beta, and
only three nonzero variables
in the latent space with the highest
value of beta. So, one can actually
choose in terms of performance and in
terms of physical properties the type of
um
the type of hyperparameter that we want
for this particular penalization.
Okay?
And
for the beta variational autoencoders,
what we also did was to develop an
algorithm for the optimality. So, we
basically
are able to recursively classify the
modes in terms of their contribution
towards the reconstruction of the
signal. So, we can actually rank them
from more to less contribution, meaning
that we have an optimal
reduced order model and an orthogonal
one, right? So, in the case of the beta
variational autoencoder, those modes are
very orthogonal. And why is that
important for interpretability?
I'll give you an example. I'm showing
you the first five modes for the
for the case of the 2D obstacles, right,
that I have uh from the beta variational
autoencoder, the POD, and the other two
autoencoder approaches.
And of course, the POD exhibits clearly
large scale shedding. That's quite clear
from the data. POD is very good at
identifying these things.
The CNN autoencoder and the hierarchical
one, they don't show you any physical
phenomenon that one can easily identify.
They show a lot of
high frequency components that are
associated with the turbulence
fluctuations, whereas the beta
variational autoencoder gives you the
large scale shedding as well. So, we can
actually obtain non-linear and
interpretable modes in the case of the
beta variational autoencoder, which is
actually quite um
quite an interesting result
if we want to try to learn some physics
from this. So, in a way
the variational autoencoder is giving us
a more compact representation. We need
fewer modes than POD
through adding higher frequency content
in the non-linearities that are present
in these modes, but retaining the
interpretability. So, that's a quite
nice property
for this uh strategy towards obtaining
these reduced order modes. Okay? So,
this is when it comes to the to the
variational autoencoders.
And the last example comes from deep
reinforcement learning for flow control.
So,
uh and this was presented by Guastoni
and others in the APS last year.
Uh essentially, when we have um
when we have
reinforcement learning framework, I have
an agent, which would be the neural
network, which is interacting with an
environment, which would be the the flow
simulation that we are trying to
develop. Uh I will given the state of
the flow, we act we decide some actions
to be applied to the environment, and we
obtain a certain reward that we want to
maximize, no?
So, the goal of the reinforcement
learning is to develop a policy pi
such that given the state of the system,
I can actually decide what are the best
actions, no? To be able to
to be able to maximize the reward, which
in our case it will be to obtain the
minimal the minimal drag in the channel.
Okay?
And uh
in this in this case, we consider a an
easy example, a 2D channel with us
basically through suction and blowing we
induce a separation bubble at the at the
lower plate.
And through actuation, after the end of
that bubble, we want to reduce the
length of that of that recirculation
region, okay? So, we have a classical
solution that is periodic,
and we want to see whether the
reinforcement learning is going to
provide us a more nuanced and more
sophisticated control approach to this,
no?
And what we do is that we observe So,
here is the flow field. In colors, you
can see the negative velocity, so this
is the bubble.
Uh the dots are the probes that we are
actually using to the flow. The arrow
will be the reward, so we want to
minimize the arrow, the separation
length. And this square over here is the
place where we are setting up the
actuation, which is modeled through a
body force that wants to emulate blowing
and suction,
and we are trying to get the amplitude
of this body force. Okay?
So, this is a little bit the setup for
this 2D case.
And what we can obtain here on the left,
I'm showing you a video, eh, so you're
actually seeing how the control looks
like. What we see is that we have two
characteristic and dominant frequencies
in this control, one associated to the
spacing of these wave packets that are
being sent, and another one eh that is
associated with the eh characteristic
time of the of the bubble itself, right?
So, it seems that we have at least two
dominant frequencies in this um
eh DRL base control strategy. And what
we can see is that we can compare the
reduction of the separation length um
with the DRL and the periodic forcing.
In the periodic forcing, we have around
20% uh bubble reduction, whereas in the
case of the DRL, we get around 30%. So,
we get better performance
um
when we are actually having the the DRL
than with a classical solution, which is
a a single frequency and it's a bit more
more simple. And we are actually
extending this um DRL framework for flow
control to perform opposition control in
the context of turbulence. So, we are
doing this in turbulent channel flow to
be able to minimize the drag and control
turbulence.
Okay? And this is a summary of what I
have discussed uh today. So, we have
used CNNs for non-intrusive sensing,
achieving very good predictions. Uh we
also develop off-wall boundary condition
strategies. Uh we applied PINs for RANS
simulations. Uh we use non-linear um
non-linear autoencoders for model
reduction. And finally, I presented you
some results that we have on deep
reinforcement learning for flow control.
Uh I would like to thank you very much
for your attention. You have my contact
information here, my email, my lab, and
my social media.
Uh so, you can contact me if you want to
discuss more, and I will be very happy
now to answer all your questions. Thank
you very much.
Thank you so much for the wonderful
talk, Ricardo. That was really really uh
wonderful. Um I learned a lot. All
right. Uh so,
we do have a um series of questions in
Q&A. I'm not sure you have a access to
the um the chat room.
But I can facilitate.
Let me see. I saw Okay, I think I do
have access.
Yeah, all right. Starting from
Starting
from the patch comment, he Yeah, he
always wants to emphasize symbolic
regression is same as the equation
discovery. Do you want to
That's okay. I just wanted to point
point the speaker to another literature
that's older than what's called what he
calls symbolic regression.
yeah. Symbolic regression is the recent
recent
It's the same thing.
We used to call it equation discovery.
Some of us still do. But let's
if I if I So, but let's move on.
Yeah, let's move on. Okay, so let's
much for the reference. I will certainly
look into it and yeah, and we can
discuss more.
Sure. Well, there's a link there.
Yeah, I saw it. I saw it. Thank you so
much.
All right, sounds good. Okay, next
question is from the Jeremy.
Uh slide 15. Yeah, so if you can go to
slide 15.
Mhm.
Are these averaged velocity profiles? Do
you have an impression of what one-time
profiles of velocity fluctuation
profiles conditioned on a particular
pressure wall pressure wall wall stress
fluctuation look like?
Yeah, so these are these are
the the statistics the turbulence
statistics, no? So, the RMS fluctuations
these are average in time and the
homogeneous directions. The
instantaneous flow can be found here.
So, these are instantaneous realizations
of the flow at particular
wall normal locations.
So, because we do predictions of 2D
planes,
it's a bit more difficult to get the
three-dimensional distribution with
conditional averaging for the for the
different events that could happen. But
some recent work that we are currently
conducting with my colleagues in Madrid,
we are actually doing predictions of the
3D flow. So, we're using GANs to to do
non-intrusive sensing of the 3D flow.
And then this conditional
representations of the flow on
particular intense events can be
viewed in more detail in those 3D cases.
Since these are 2D, it's a bit more
difficult to really get um
good representations of the events
in that conditional average.
All right. Well,
thank you.
Next question is um by Pat.
I think
Okay, so he asked that could you revisit
what you are predicting? What are you
predicting?
It's related to the previous question. I
mean, I it you RMS is
has always been a questionable metric,
but at least I I I want to understand
what where it's coming from. What What
are you comparing?
Yeah, RMS, I mean, in the context of a
wall-bounded turbulence, this is
a pretty standard physical quantity that
one is
I believe it's standard. Wait, with RMS,
you mean root mean squared error,
correct?
Root mean square fluctuations.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
No wonder I'm confused. Okay, so so so
it's not it's not RMSE, it's it's
no, no.
Okay.
So, I'm I'm sorry because the audience,
of course, is a bit heterogeneous. So,
this is a bit more on the fluid
mechanics side. So, the flow the
turbulent flow is fluctuating. What you
can see here are the patterns of the
fluctuations. And then one can take the
RMS of those fluctuations, which are
very important physical quantities in
the context of turbulent flows.
What What is it again, RMS?
Sorry? What is it again, RMS?
Root mean square fluctuations.
Fluctuations at
spatially.
Yes. So, the fluctuations are averaged
in time and in the two homogeneous
directions. So, in the case of a
channel, the streamwise and spanwise
directions. And they are plotted as a
function of the distance from the wall.
So, this is this is this is this is some
kind of measure of how much variance
there is.
Yeah, exactly. The variance of the
fluctuations. So, what you can see here
And so, so this is an aggregate measure
and you were trying to predict this
aggregate measure. Is that correct?
Yeah, I'm predicting the magnitude of
the fluctuations, the the variance of
the fluctuations at different distances
from the wall. Exactly.
All right. All right. Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
Okay, sounds good.
Uh
Yeah.
PINNs. Uh
another question
by Pat.
Do you really need another or or Pat
acronym?
Not a question. Not a question.
Just complaining about acronyms.
That you need to talk to George
Karniadakis, no, who developed this the
PINNs framework.
Well, you don't have but you know, I'm
talking to you because you're using it.
You I mean, you you didn't actually use
it. You you you said it here,
physics-informed neural networks. That
was fine.
It's just that
that
then
if if you if you start putting that in
papers, you're going to make them less
accessible to people who don't know
what's going on. And and and AI in
general, maybe maybe fluid dynamics,
too, but AI in general has been
really overused
acronyms like this for decades.
I just wanted to discourage it. That's
why I was making fun of you.
Well, it's unfortunately it's getting
popular these days.
I I believe it. That's why we have to
stamp it out now.
Well, at least I highlighted in my slide
what it stands for so you can
you can you can have it. But I agree
that there are too many acronyms. That's
absolutely true.
All right, sounds good.
I mean, part of it is that I'm I'm
concerned that especially about hiding
it, if people are going to say, "Well,
physics-informed neural networks as
opposed to physics-informed other
approaches." Because there are other
approaches to doing physics-informed
this model discovery
neural nets.
Yeah, that's true. That's true. Yeah.
So, there's a subtle distinction that we
have to be clear about.
And and I agree I mean in particular
PINs
I mean from the name itself you don't
get the full picture of what it actually
is. Because I mean it's it's more
reducing the machinery of deep learning
to solve PDEs. It's not really It's not
so much embedding physics in the
network. It's more just solving a PDE
with a
machinery of deep learning. So in in
even the name in this case I mean there
is some things that one could actually
argue about the name itself.
So yeah I mean it's important to to know
exactly the methods that we are talking
about and what they actually do.
Yeah. I mean the the way you used the
PINs here is um
you put the residual of the PDE and then
minimize it in the training
There is actually two terms in the loss.
I didn't get into too much detail but
one term is to minimize the residual of
the PDE inside the domain and the other
term is to match the boundary conditions
because you need to be able to match the
boundary conditions as well. And then
that's the the two terms of the loss
that we have here.
Yeah I remember
I heard a talk a few months back in some
somewhere where where someone pointed
out there were very different radically
different ways to use physics knowledge
in this context, right? One of them is
as a regularization term but there are
other ways too
and and and you're using you're using it
to regularize things. Is that correct?
Yeah.
In this in this case even it's just
solving the PDE. We're just Our loss
function is based on the residual of the
PDE. But of course I mean another way
that we have we have tried is um through
embedding in the non-intrusive sensing
so in this you know in this predictions
that you see here, right? You can use
some of the physical properties that you
know about the flow for example
incompressibility to simplify your
prediction. So that becomes a step
additionally on the
data-driven approach that you're using
which of course yeah I mean embedding
physics in this neural network models
becomes a little bit um
yeah, a little bit confusing with the
nomenclature because there are many
different ways of doing it and they get
confused quite easily, yes.
All right. Um let's move on. Um the next
question is by Jeremy. Uh let's see. The
fourth uh for the channel flows, do you
have an impression if wall shear stress
or pressure is more predictive for
velocity fluctuations? I think pressure
measurements may be easier for an
experimenter.
a very good question. So, um you're
right. Pressure measurements are easier
from an experimental point of view,
although the wall shear stress um
measurements are becoming more and more
feasible with enough spatial resolution.
Um
turns out that uh to predict the U
prime,
the uh streamwise wall shear stress is
the most important quantity, which makes
sense, of course, because they both
contain information of the streaks. To
predict the V prime is the pressure,
that one that is more important.
Uh so, depending on what you want to
predict, you may have to measure
different things. And this is something
that we have been also analyzing the
context of uh Shapley, the Shapley
framework for explainability. So, that's
actually
um so, this Shapley framework gives us
something very consistent with the
physical intuition that one can actually
get for these uh flow cases.
All right. Next one is by Pat. Uh how
large are your uh training sets of CNNs
and how many runs do you need to
do you need for the uh uh reinforcement
learning uh application?
So, the CNN is for the non-intrusive
sensing part, which is this first part.
Uh we are talking uh around 5 to 10,000
snapshots of training. That's what we
what we need for this uh for these
predictions. For the reinforcement
learning, uh I mean, it's expensive. Uh
here I have some
um some results as a function of the
time step in a particular episode, but
we're talking hundreds of episodes. Uh
and that's for the
uh so, these are the time steps of a
particular episode.
That's for the 2D case. For the
turbulent channel case, it's even more
that one needs.
But we have we're using a framework
where we have parallelized the the
exploration space, so we can have
16, 32 different processes running
episodes in parallel and communicating
so that it can be done a bit more
efficiently. But yeah, but it's the
exploration it's quite costly in these
cases, yes.
It sounds good. The next one is
from Joyita. He wants to connect with
you later via
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I guess my information I mean, I
can write my email in the chat and I
guess my information will be available.
You see it also in the in the slides. So
feel free to email me. I will be happy
to provide you more information, to have
a call and discuss more. Absolutely.
All right, sounds good. Okay, going back
to the pins. My
my questions
You need a colocation points.
Yes.
How many colocation points did you
So this is this gives you an idea of the
This is an extra slide
of the
periodic hill. So that's that's a
typical mesh that we have for the
periodic hill.
Which So basically the amount of
colocation points is a trade-off. You
don't need to resolve the gradients as
much as you would have in a RANS
simulation. You have a coarser mesh, but
still you need to be able to propagate
the information of the residual from the
domain into the boundaries because the
loss function needs to also match the
boundaries. So you cannot get away with
three points or something like that. You
need to have a reasonable resolution,
but you can have coarser than with other
numerical methods.
Right. Okay. If you go If you go to
slide 27,
you apply the autoencoder to the some
sort of 3D channel
problem.
The urban environment, the simplified
urban environment.
Oh, simplified urban environment. So,
the size of the data would be not that
This one, right?
A high resolution.
How
How big of the the simulation data is
this?
So, this are 1,200 instantaneous fields.
The simulate This is a simulation that,
if I remember correctly, is around 100
million grid points in the the full
domain.
And we extract a 2D plane that is at the
center of the obstacles, so cutting
through the middle.
And it's a spectrum interpolated on a
mesh of this size, so 96 * 192 grid
points. So, we really reduce the amount
of data for the problem. Although, the
Well, the multiscale character of the
complex turbulent flow is there. It's
present in these snapshots that we
consider.
Okay, so you you treated the data to 2D
and then train the CNN.
Yes, we only consider a 2D a 2D plane.
This could be done in 3D as well, of
course, but as a first assessment is
just a 2D the
So, when you go from 2D to 3D, the
scalability of the training of the
neural net CNN should be considered. Do
you have any idea how you're going to do
that?
Yeah, that's a very good point.
And of course, we have run into some
some problems of the the scalability of
of TensorFlow itself, no? So, we have to
to fix some of the
parallelization of the training in
TensorFlow.
So, we are working on some larger cases,
2D much larger and 3D. And yeah, I mean,
it seems that it's it's feasible, it
works, but
but there's quite some some work to be
done on the on the computer science
aspect of it. Yeah.
Sounds good. All right.
Okay. Um
Um all right, another question by Juan.
He asked, "Did you try different
sampling strategies for the work of
brands with pins? And if so, did it make
any difference in the results?"
Uh what do you mean with sampling?
I think he meant the collocation points
if
If you If you mean the colloc-
Great. Yeah, the collocation. Exactly.
So, for the collocation, it's connected
with a discussion that we were having
before. So, yeah, we had to play a bit
with the distribution of the mesh. It's
convenient to have, you know, I mean, as
you would have in a numerical method,
finer resolution where there are
larger gradients, but it's not a big
requirement because of the automatic
differentiation. The more important
thing is that the points are a quite
uniformly distributed through the
domain, so you can actually match
effectively the boundaries. So, that's
the That's the key. Because PINs, the
problem is that PINs will always give
you something even if the boundary data
is not consistent with the flow and
things are a bit tricky. So, you should,
you know, make sure that your mesh is at
least fine enough to be able to
propagate that information effectively.
And the quality of the boundary
conditions is going to define also the
quality of your
of your solution as well.
All right.
Uh
last question from me. If I think you
introduced the two different autoencoder
for the reduced order models, one was
the hierarchical autoencoder and the
other one was CNN-based autoencoder.
Yeah.
When you compare those two autoencoders,
which which one was better in terms of
the compression? Like which
So, the the CNN autoencoder was better.
I can show you now the results. The less
things you impose, the better the the
compression. So, I think the results are
here, right?
So, the autoencoder The CNN autoencoder
gets 94% of the signal with five modes,
the hierarchical 91%
and the variational 87%. The
hierarchical with five modes is worse
than the CNN because you have the that
additional property of optimality.
Yeah. They're ranked. More structures in
CNN hierarchical one.
But it's more interpretable and
the hierarchical
Then So, the hierarchical is not more
interpretable,
but the modes are ranked in terms of
their energetic contribution
contribution to the reconstruction. So
if you want to truncate, if you want to
have a reusable model and truncate, the
hierarchical is better.
I see. Got it. All right.
Sounds good.
Um
All right. Okay, so I I guess that's
about it.
Well,
if there's no more questions, I mean,
let's let's thank our speaker Ricardo
for the wonderful talk he gave us.
Thank you very much for the invitation.
And as he said, if if you guys want to
directly contact the Ricardo, please do
so and you know
you know, initiate the collaboration,
future collaboration. That's all about
this seminar, the motivation of this
seminar. So well, thank you so much for
the good talk and keep in touch.
Thank you very much and yeah, have a
great day. Bye-bye.
All right.